why don't you give an overview of your
theory for those who are uninitiated a
broad Strokes view well the ctmu is a
theory of everything there are two kinds
of Theory of Everything one of them is a
physical Theory usually it's related to
a unified field theory in some way which
means the forces of nature is supposed
to be unified into one General Force um
but of course that's only part of
reality my theory is a theory of
everything in the metaphysical sense it
actually has to conform to certain
logical criteria which in philosophy and
metaphysics govern what a what a Theory
of Everything has to be so I like to
characterize it as the language that
reality speaks to itself about itself it
is a language a language is an algebraic
structure this is a particular kind of
language that reality actually uses to
communicate with itself and to make
decisions regarding how it models itself
which is another way to say how it
evolves